[Música]
pois é quando eu tinha quatro anos como
qualquer criança adorava brincar na
areia brincar com a água que criança não
gosta da minha verdadeira paixão era o
meu velotrol e foi justamente num
domingo ensolarado num clube da cidade
que os meus pais me levaram enquanto
eles estavam conversando com os meus
tios e amigos
estava eu lá andando no meu velotrol
dando voltas no meu velotrol mas de
repente de uma forma surpreendente
inesperada caótica e preocupante
eu me desequilibrei e cair na piscina
vocês podem imaginar o desespero dos
meus pais e dos amigos mas muito antes
que qualquer um deles pudesse se
movimentar
lá estava eu de forma instintiva batendo
os braços as pernas e alcançando
rapidamente aborda esse foi um momento
extraordinário onde eu tive que me virar
eu tive que descobrir todas as
habilidades e ferramentas instrumentos
que nem mesmo conhecia e dessa forma me
virar até a borda conseguir sobreviver
àquela situação caótica inesperada de
uma certa forma no dia a dia da cidade
nós temos também que sobreviver a esse
caso o ano a essa dificuldade
nós temos os problemas da enchente das
inundações que a cada dia e de forma
periódica nos alcançam são inúmeras
vidas que são perdidas são problemas
nós temos uma série de causas para esses
diversos problemas nós temos a questão
do nosso lixo urbano dos resíduos
sólidos onde a maior parte desses
resíduos ainda é despejado de forma
inadequada
nós temos uma uma séria deficiência no
campo da educação ambiental
uma outra questão elementar que ainda é
muito mal resolvida diz respeito ao
saneamento básico
grande parte do nosso esgoto dos nossos
efluentes ainda são lançados in natura
nos rios nos córregos comprometendo não
só o meio ambiente à qualidade de vida
mas a qualidade da água ea
disponibilidade desse recurso tão
importante para a nossa vida
e são essas questões que dizem respeito
ao nosso ir e vir no dia a dia a nossa
mobilidade e que acabam consumindo
também grande parte da nossa jornada
diária aquele tempo que a gente poderia
estar com a família adquirindo mais
conhecimento
bento tendo acesso ao lazer à cultura o
mesmo ao ócio
nós desperdiçamos nesse movimento
pendular casa-trabalho-casa estudo além
de diversos outros problemas
eu não sei vocês se vocês sabem mas o
país perde cerca de 50 mil vidas por
conta dos acidentes é dos acidentes de
trânsito no país além de outros
problemas como a questão da qualidade do
ar e do ruído ou a própria de economia
pois nós perdemos grande parte dos
nossos recursos nesses problemas
associados à imobilidade o mesmo
pensando no nosso transporte coletivo
nós temos um problema de insegurança e
ineficiência desconforto o que acaba
dificultando a opção por esse modo de
transporte
infelizmente o país fez uma opção muito
cara para todos nós que foi uma opção
rodoviária está abrimos mão de trás de
um transporte sobre trilhos de alta
qualidade que teria capacidade de levar
muitas pessoas e fizemos essa opção pelo
modal rodoviário esta holo em ti e
principalmente por conta dessa
ineficiência do nosso transporte
coletivo e por conta também de uma
política que incentiva o uso do nosso
transporte individual
nós estamos sempre fazendo a opção pelo
carro e pela moto em detrimento de um
transporte não poluente e eficiente e
que poderia contribuir no dia a dia para
que a gente tivesse mais tempo para a
nossa família e são todos esses esses
aspectos da cidade que nos fazem
refletir em relação a quais as
possibilidades que nós temos para
melhorar a qualidade de vida afinal de
contas somos mais 84 por cento das
pessoas vivem nas cidades a maior parte
das pessoas aqui está
se considerarmos as regiões
metropolitanas
anos praticamente a totalidade da
população é urbana
aqui temos diversos problemas mas também
inúmeras possibilidades
o fato é que esse processo de migração
do campo para a cidade se deu de uma
forma muito intensa nas últimas décadas
e ela não veio acompanhada da
infraestrutura necessária dos serviços
necessários para garantir a nossa
qualidade de vida
mas eu falei diversos aspectos
preocupantes em relação à cidade mas
também nós temos que lembrar que a
cidade é o local onde tudo acontece
onde nós temos as oportunidades da troca
do conhecimento da inovação na cidade a
cultura acontece na cidade os negócios
florescem na cidade nós temos a festa
nós temos o resgate da vida em
comunidade
essa essa questão nos abre as diversas
possibilidades e oportunidades também
que a cidade nos apresenta
mas a cidade não é homogênea nós temos
partes da cidade que tem uma
infraestrutura extraordinária com
serviço de educação de saúde mas agimos
lazer de altíssima qualidade e com
indicadores de escala global mas
infelizmente isso não retrata a
totalidade da cidade principalmente as
famílias de menor renda têm muita
dificuldade de acessar e serviços e não
encontrando as possibilidades da moradia
próximo das oportunidades os locais com
boa infraestrutura elas acabam ocupando
as áreas mais vulneráveis distanciando
das oportunidades muitas vezes ocupando
áreas irregulares em áreas de risco ou
até mesmo ocupando as margens dos
mananciais e comprometendo a qualidade
de vida não só delas mas também
viabilizando com a qualidade de vida
urbana ou mesmo metropolitana o fato é
que essa desigualdade acaba se
refletindo no nosso tecido urbano
basta uma leitura relativamente simples
para perceber como é que a cidade não
tem sido inclusiva e tem segregado as
pessoas em relação à sua renda
limitando aí as oportunidades de
crescimento e de desenvolvimento e é
interessante observar que mesmo diante
de um pacto global que envolve quase
duas centenas de países e que envolve
objetivos do desenvolvimento sustentável
uma nova agenda urbana recentemente
discutida e aprovada essas políticas
essas diretrizes essas ações ainda não
foram incorporadas ao nosso dia a dia o
nosso cotidiano urbano
então temos uma situação claramente de
um discurso de sustentabilidade e que
ainda não foi incorporada ao nosso dia a
dia
nós temos um avanço em vários campos da
tecnologia mas infelizmente isso ainda
não tem sido incorporado ao planejamento
e à gestão das nossas cidades
estamos diante claramente de um modelo
completamente esgotado a verdade é que
nós continuamos planejando gerindo
projetando as cidades
da mesma forma que fizemos nas últimas
décadas e mesmo assim esperamos
resultados diferentes nós precisamos de
uma verdadeira virada na cidade que
promova o resgate da vida em qualidade à
vida em comunidade que promova a
retomada da qualidade de vida
ou será que iremos afogar
ou será que iremos sobreviver a esse
difícil momento essa é uma pergunta que
se apresenta a todos nós
é justamente nesse contexto há dois anos
atrás que nós iniciamos um processo de
virada criativa e de virada da cidade
afinal de contas se a cidade é nossa nós
temos que elaborar esse roteiro da
mudança e justamente com esses objetivos
nós reunimos pessoas da comunidade e
lideranças sociais
pessoas de todas as regiões da cidade e
formadores de opinião um movimento de
luta pela moradia
reunimos também pessoas da área cultural
da área empresarial e de forma conjunta
e coletiva nós começamos a pensar nos
problemas da nossa cidade e começamos a
tentar elaborar as soluções e é um
processo extremamente simples pois ele
parte da elaboração de desenhos livres
isso mesmo as pessoas são convidadas a
elaborar desenhos livres e através dessa
expressão elas conseguem incorporar o
seu desejo as suas expectativas a sua
vivência a sua bagagem cultural e
principalmente coloca a formulação das
propostas na mão daqueles que vivenciam
os problemas da cidade
só quem sabe onde o calo aperta sabe
quais são as ferramentas os instrumentos
quais são as soluções para melhorar a
qualidade de vida e talvez isso pareça
óbvio para todos mas não é
nós temos não só no país mas realmente
nas principais cidades ainda um modelo
clássico de planejar e gerenciar as
cidades aonde basicamente a reunião de
especialistas e gestores de pessoas de
notório saber
morar diagnósticos ea partir desse
diagnóstico dos problemas e pensar nas
soluções
só depois dessa etapa é que esse
trabalho é que esse instrumental é
levado a conhecimento das pessoas é
levado para a participação das pessoas
para que elas possam refinar contribuir
e colaborar com aquele diagnóstico e com
aquelas soluções muitas vezes projetadas
por pessoas que não vivenciam os
problemas da cidade ou que habita uma
determinada área da cidade que não
representa toda a diversidade de
percepções de viver de bagagens e é
justamente esse é um processo
participativo colaborativa um processo
simples onde as pessoas conseguem
através de desenhos livres e estabelecer
soluções para diversas as temáticas da
cidade como o meio ambiente
a mobilidade habitação de interesse
social o desenvolvimento comum
o mico para as ações na área da cultura
da educação e do lazer é a criação ea
construção de um repertório genuinamente
popular um repertório não só
participativo mas um repertório que
conhece e reconhece o papel de cada um
na sociedade criando epal tando aí sim
os gestores os especialistas para que a
partir desse repertório popular eles
possam desenvolver através de seus
conhecimentos a outros instrumentos e
ferramentas para potencializar soluções
e esse trabalho consegue extrair
soluções pontuais
desde uma feira numa rua e identificar
áreas utilizadas identificar por exemplo
a possibilidade de uma praça no bairro
ou mesmo soluções muito maiores integrar
lógicos áreas de lazer ou mesmo soluções
para o transporte urbano e até mesmo o
metropolitano
essa tem sido uma experiência que tem
suscitado a mobilização das pessoas
nós já erramos essa experiência em
diversas cidades e as pessoas na medida
em que conhecem essas novas habilidades
começa a exercitar essas novas
habilidades
elas percebem que elas podem ser os
protagonistas da verdadeira mudança é
justamente é fazendo um paralelo com com
a questão do menino de 4 anos que teve
que através de habilidades que até mesmo
ele desconhecia
ele teve que lidar com surpreendente ele
teve que lidar com aparente é a situação
caótica que aparentemente ele se
encontrava ele teve que ligasse lidar
com uma situação incrível que ele teve
que responder rapidamente com novas
habilidades para sobreviver é que nós
temos que exercitar essa questão de que
se a cidade é das pessoas a essas
pessoas é que têm que elaborar o seu
roteiro da mudança a verdadeira virada
da cidade
a verdadeira virada da cidade
instruída é formulada é projetada e é
pautada a partir das pessoas
muito obrigado